[Music]
I actually chose to come here because um
well first they have such a great
undergraduate art program yeah I would
highly recommend the program it has a
lot of experiences all packaged into six
weeks which is really really great it's
definitely a good trial run of college a
lot of students are interested in
developing also their technical
abilities as well as their artistic
abilities and I think seeing you offers
the ability to do that and when I came
to this program it was really
overwhelming the amount of material that
was available to all of us it doesn't
seem like hard work because everything
revolves around like unique ideas and
they make the teachers really make it
like engaging and interesting every
project we do what this program provides
for them is the ability to update and
maintain a strong portfolio it's been a
really amazing summer so far I mean all
the students that I'm with in class are
very unique an individual is such really
a great experience especially with art
because you get so many different
perspectives a lot of the students come
back and they say that it gave them a
great start and that they were able to
it just propelled them through their
first drawing class a first painting
class first concept class they were able
to click in and avoid a lot of that
adjustment and anxiety that some of the
freshmen have I really like the
professor's here I think the programs
that they come up with are very
challenging vigorous but in a way that
it's very doable yeah it's nice because
it teaches you to look at your teachers
not just as teachers but as fellow
artists and mentors you really should
attends the Carnegie Mellon summer art
program because the faculty is amazing
and inspiring and the students are so
willing to work and it's a hundred times
better than I ever could've thought it
would have been
you